le d'écart avec eux vous savez deux
étapes qui ont été annulées pour raisons
de sécurité aujourd'hui un point aérien
est organisée pour acheminer les motos
en revanche les camions les voitures ont
pris la route pour rejoindre bamako
julia boman ne telle qu'elle est
ce matin grasse matinée pour les motards
la course ayant été annulé c'est par
avion qu'ils iront à bamako 6h du matin
les motos sont chargées les pilotes
partiront à mites
moi j'ai peur de prendre l'avion alors
c'est pas la solution que je préfère
j'adore piloter j'aurais voulu y aller
par mes propres moyens
mais ceci dit l'organisation a pris la
bonne décision je pense plus de 80 motos
a transféré de radon trois rotations
d'avions pendant la journée et pour
protéger les machines des matelas
renommée tht côté voitures et camions
c'est par la route
ils rejoindront bamako au long
enfin beaucoup de civilisations et
villages les traversées à 30 à l'heure
donc ça va nous prendre douze heures de
route sont d'une ni piège
après dix jours de course c'est presque
comme une journée de repos